e
e e
good morning everyone I'd like to call
to order day two of the governor's
capital budget hearings uh if you didn't
catch the governor's opening remarks
yesterday today uh what he stated was
typically as as many of you may know we
we issue every buy between 120 $130
million in the in the capital budget uh
this year's requests for funds came in
at 1.3 billion so uh 1.1 billion of that
is coming from general fund sources so
um just doing the basic math uh 90% of
these projects under our current
guidelines L are not going to be
approved so it's um I think the uh the
headline on the union leader today was
uh Governor's agencies lower your
expectations so
um the bottom line is the New Hampshire
economy uh is probably in the best shape
it's ever been uh but when you come off
a period of U uh spending which is what
we which was what we've done over the
last few years including both in the cap
both in the capital budget the operating
budget with 800 roughly $800 million of
surplus
spending uh and with uh tax cuts that
were
enacted uh we're going to have some hard
decisions to make over the next uh few
months uh including not the capital
budget but the operating budget so uh
while everything is uh strong and robust
uh just a cautionary tale of of
tightening to
come uh and on that cherry note uh I'd
like to bring up uh the first is fishing
game department like to invite you up
for your
presentation good morning um as a
30-year career Farmer in the state of
New Hampshire I certainly understand not
having enough money in the
budget uh but with that I would like to
discuss some of the goals that we have
at fishing game um predominantly we're
still working on on hatcheries um I'm
sure everybody here is well aware that
we will be rebuilding our hatchery in
New Hampton with a goer Grant of about
$58
million but we have excuse me that
leaves us with four other hatcheries in
the state that that are in desperate
need of
repair um we had received $4.6 million
in capital budget I believe it was two
budget Cycles ago and once again we
rolled it over to keep it alive during
the last budget cycle but we weren't
ready to commit to what we wanted to do
um we were looking at the entire
Hatchery system and we just needed more
time to study the problem um we believe
at this point we do have a good plan on
what we think the other four hatcheries
are going to need um our primary goal is
to go in and repair any structural
issues at the buildings predominantly
roofs uh there are some uh block walls
that need to be repaired uh reeal the
raceways and then um as we studied the
issue at the new new Durham Hatchery um
one of the things that became very um
evident to us was is that we had we had
underestimated the impact that predation
has on our fish and on our management at
these hatcheries and how that impacts
water quality at the hatcheries so those
are the three areas that we're very
interested in trying to uh plug some of
the holes that we have at the four
hatcheries
um the 4.6 million that was approved uh
was only approved to be spent at the new
Durham Hatchery as we we went through
the process at New Durham it would cost
us roughly $60 million just to treat the
water at the new Durham Hatchery to meet
the new 12 part per billion phosphorus
level that uh EPA uh has given us for
our discharge permit we do not believe
at this time that that is a good
investment um for example we believe
we'll be spending less than that to
totally rebuild the Hatchery at New
Hampton and we think excuse me we think
that that's a much better investment not
only will we be able to maintain clean
water but we'll be able to improve our
ability to raise
fish
um we would like um we what we need to
do at New Hampton at this point we are
going to meet the uh NEP permit by
reducing Fish Production so if you're
familiar with the Hatchery um we have a
series of round tanks at the bottom end
of the Hatchery and that those are the
tanks that we will continue to use the
rest of the Hatchery we will not be
using for the foreseeable future so we
would like to erect a office uh some
office space and bathroom spaces down at
that end of the
Hatchery um this will probably be a
portable type structure whether it be a
a modular home or whether it be a work
trailer type structure that's what we
would like to erect down there we would
like to um uh build uh some predation uh
structures over those over those
tanks um the the other reason for
building the office down there is we
think we could come up with a much more
energy efficient uh building that would
take a lot less money to heat um and be
a lot smaller building um as we go down
through um we would like to then spend
any of the Surplus the uh 4.6 million
the balance of the 4.6 million uh at the
Berlin Hatchery we need to do some
re-roofing of Hatchery buildings um
replacing of windows and doors and place
um what is currently a 25-year-old
Predator control structures there they
all have um worn out and need to be
replaced at the Milford Hatchery we need
to replace the roof on the main Hatchery
building repair the ventilation system
and perform mold uh
remediation we need to R roof two of the
employees houses we have some structural
issues with the block wall and the
Hatchery building that will need to be
repaired we need to install an auto
sampling unit at this uh at the
discharge location all of the other new
auto sampling units that we did uh
basically we just were able to attach
them to the end of the line and build a
structure over them uh this one we're
going to have to do some considerable uh
repiping in order to um make it so that
it'll work uh once again we'll be
sealing the Raceway tanks and replacing
doors and windows um this is for our new
request um we would this is where we
were going to invest in um the the $2.1
million request is for uh Predator
control me uh measures to be built at
the New Hampton Hatchery I'm sorry at
the Milford Hatchery at the Twin
Mountain Hatchery we'll replace the
roofs on the hatch house employees house
garage and Visitor Center seal the
raceways replace doors and windows and
repair the corner of the Hatchery
building um at the Warren Hatchy we need
to re-roof offices the office Visitor
Center and the employee resident and
Place doors and windows at the
facility um also as part of our as also
as part of our Capital request this year
we are also requesting $66,500 for
Inland Fisheries equipment which will
consist of a
um uh what they call an autonomous
portable scientific echos Sounder so
basically a sonar unit that helps us uh
track and keep and and develop better
research numbers on populations in our
in our big lakes uh as well as a new
generator for the Berlin facility um our
facilities and land division wishes to
replace a a heavy trailer for hauling
heavy equipment as well as a 25y old
backo I'd be happy to oh um one other
thing uh we have developed a really good
presentation on our new Hampton Hatchery
project I know that's something that
doesn't necessarily come before this
committee but at your leisure we would
would certainly be willing to come back
and make that presentation if you folks
have an interest in that we have
presented it in the house of the fishing
game committee as well as in the Senate
uh to their committee but we'd be happy
to come back and uh offer to do it here
too are there any
questions I believe there are uh my my
question is if you could give us an
update on on the hatcheries and the last
thing I remember hearing was that they
were about to go out for bids I think
you you either on the new Hampton
project yes okay so yes we have um the
engineering firm has been selected it's
HDR um we have put out to bid for uh the
bidding process for the contract
managers we received uh four bids we
Whitt that down to three and actually
when I get done here today I'll have
another meeting dealing with that okay
how how did the bids come in in relation
to expectations we believe that we'll be
able to build this project you know on
budget but once again you need to
remember we're only at 30% design this
this this type of building uh
contractual agreement a little different
than what we're used to doing um because
usually you have 100% design before you
go get the contracted to build on it so
we're bringing in the contract manager
to be part of the design team uh it
allows us several things number one
maybe a little bit better the idea is is
that when we get done I I don't want to
have a a a100 million Hatchery design
and a $55 million Hatchery budget so it
allows a little bit more reality
throughout the uh to take place during
the design better communication it also
allows a contract manager to pre-order
some of this equipment is pretty
specialized in today's world some of
this uh some of this equipment has some
long lead times between ordering and
delivery so that allows us to try to
pre-order items that we're going to need
um so that we can meet to go for
deadline of completion of construction
by December 26 okay uh one other
question for me which is could you just
explain what the predatory control is
and the hat is just like a a tar or
covering on the so what we're looking at
um if you've been to our hatch some of
our old hatcheries uh we've used um
several different methods one was they
basically kind of look like um um an
igloo or a tent it's a canvas structure
that sits over round tanks the those
were very successful we've used some uh
basically their Greenhouse Hoops with
netting um they can be successful we had
some problems at one of our facilities
where we attached them to concrete
raceways where we actually attached the
steel structure of the greenhouse hoop
to the top of the raceways and under
snow load or ice load we loost you know
that it cracked the raceways and and did
damage to our wasteway so we got some
issues with those but we we I still
believe that we can you know better
better management of it or better
placement of it we might be able to to
continue to use some of that um and then
yes what we're looking at and if you'd
allow me to use the word coverall that
is a that is a name brand but basically
these are the fabric quantit Huts that
that you see uh quite often used in
agriculture um our DOT uses some
structures similar to this for salt
sheds um so that would be what we would
go to one of the things that we're
trying to do is is originally a lot of
our uh structures just barely fit over
the raceways and that did not that
basically meant that you know they would
catch the fish in Nets and then have to
haul the fish out of the structure to
load into the truck so it was very labor
intensive um it it causes you know
stress injuries in our staff so we would
like to be able to provide um most of
our setups where we'd be able to put the
truck inside the Predator control
structure we have two typ of predators
basically ground Predators so we you
know some of our early thoughts really
didn't was not effective at keeping uh
uh otter and mink out of these out of
the tanks and then the other predators
are are bird Predators anything you know
Eagles and Ospreys and King Fishers and
stuff like
that um that helps at the end I was like
does he mean birds eat the fish my
predator control but apparently birds
and otters um I have a couple questions
one is um your uh your Capital requests
are funded by the fishing game fund
correct and you have a debt service line
in your budget um I don't believe
I uh no I do because we are making debt
payments now do you know roughly how
much a year you're paying now I do not
know what that is I'd be happy to get
that no it's I I don't need it today or
anything so um that's helpful I I had a
question about there's a lot of talk
about employee housing how many
um I presume I presume these aren't
people who like permanently live there
it's overnight no they are like so like
fred is a guy who like for five years
lives at a hatchery we correct we have
how many um I let me stop and think I
think I have three in Berlin one in Twin
Mountain
two in
Milford two in New
Hampton Warren Hatchery has one that
we're currently using but then an
apartment that we're not currently using
because of fire Cod
issues and so do so the issue is is that
um much like an agriculture problems
happen in the middle of the night um
this practice uh we've been doing this
since the beginning on our hatcheries
where we have staff that actually live
at the hatcheries so if there's an alarm
that goes off or an issue that comes up
or they're out checking uh that puts our
staff there to be able to handle
emergencies in the middle of the night
um it's in the world of agriculture it's
not uncommon in the world of hatcheries
it's not uncommon I understand for most
state employees the idea of supplying
housing alongside a job is a little
different but there are some
requirements that come with that no
there's a I mean it it's interesting I
was looking at Old Personnel rules and
there's a we we have a whole whole set
of rules on uh compens if housing is
part of your compensation yeah and I
thought I wonder how many people that
affects but
mostly back in the day when the state
had Farms you had like for example at
UNH they have housing for some of their
staff at UNH alongside the Farms um you
know the state uh prison I would assume
had housing the state hospital would
have would have had housing with those
Farms but they're all gone
lot of the mar going yeah anyway thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony appreciate it
you like to call up now the department
of
safety good morning good morning
good morning uh Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Robert Quinn
I'm the commissioner of the Department
of Safety and with me today is Amy
Newbury our director of
administration today we will speak to
the Department of safety's FY 2627
capital budget requests these Capital
requests are critical to achieving our
mission which is to continually enhance
the safety security and quality of life
in New Hampshire through professional
collaborative and Innovative service to
all the reach of these projects support
the health and safety of our dedicated
staff by addressing concerns in two of
our buildings including Water and Power
you'll also hear of Our IT projects that
have a large community and stakeholder
reach bringing Revenue into the state to
support Public Safety Statewide and also
within our local communities Amy will
now spend time discussing and addressing
each of these pro project requests we'll
be happy to answer any question that you
may have throughout the presid
Amy thank you commissioner good morning
Amy Newbery director of administration
as the commissioner stated I'll give you
a brief overview of each of our five
Capital project requests leaving time
for questions and I'm going to begin on
page four of your slide Deck with our
first request for Road tool and in
preparing for this presentation today I
was sharing with friends that I would be
talking about Road Road tool which
prompted a a conversation and discussion
around toll booth so I thought I'd start
with a definition that I'm going to be
talking about the gas taex in the 22
cents so um our current rotal Bureau is
responsible for the collection of the
single largest source of revenue for the
highway
fund for State fisal year 23 that total
was
153 million
our current automated fuel tax system is
installed on
onr we have been using this system since
2008 we are under an active maintenance
so it's been upgraded over years by the
vendor it is at the end of its useful
life we had gone out to RFP in
2023 for a new cloud-based subscription
platform
at the time we decided not to move
forward with the new platform as there
is a large upfront cost hence the
capital
request and the increase in the annual
maintenance
cost the plan is to go out for RFP again
in
2025 and Implement in
2026 our current contract expires June
30 of 20
26 our future state of course would be
to support ongoing efficient Revenue
collection for motor fuel tools and move
this to the cloud-based
system we are looking at a
2.8 um million doll
request our second capital project
request is for the gun range training fa
facility at 1.5
million our current state of this
training building is under sized at 23
by 20 this shed if you will is run off
generator power there is no restrooms or
running water it is it's an inadequate
facility um and it's we really need a
facility that we can utilize year
round funds would be used um to for
classrooms audio visual equipment um a
dedicated weapons room cleaning
facilities certainly power and install
running Waters facilities so um and the
training facility for inuse um use of
force classroom training Force scenario
and practical training and live fire
firearms training the new facility the
new training facility would properly
support the increasing training demands
of the New Hampshire State
Police request three for troop e
renovation so over time the department
of safety has been evaluating the health
of all of the troop stations and this
has been through um really assessing the
buildings as well as all systems within
each of the buildings and putting forth
um request to for renovation of all of
its sites and Troop e is really up for
renovation and through this analysis
it's been identified that um in troopy
the electrical systems water issues
septic doors um this trivia is next for
us um you can see certainly through um
some of these photos um we really need
to pay attention to this
building there is some opportunity is on
page seven that we've identified in just
this land and addressing one of our
other issues with um the impound law in
conquered that doesn't really allow
space and it's really um we need more
space for the car unit and um that that
is just we don't have enough space in
conquered and this would allow um
additional space for investigators to
process complex cases so we're looking
to move um established that in Tamworth
through this
renovation Capital request four is for
Grants management
software in fiscal year 23 oura
expenditures for
over10
million um this software would really
this is really pre-award so this would
support our local communities it's
forward facing it would allow
transparency in the application process
in fiscal year 23 we had over
253 applications that only continue to
increase in fiscal year
24 um and this is by month ending May so
there's this is only continuing to grow
um our current state is really grants
applications managed through Excel
spreadsheets it's a manual process there
is no transparency for our local
communities in this process to find out
where their application is currently
they are calling and waiting for a call
back um to find out their status so we
really want to create through the system
efficiencies in the process as well as
transpar transparency for our
stakeholders so our future state would
create those efficiencies Implement a
new centralized Grant management system
to streamline processes improve
efficiencies across across groups
centralized data standardized processes
and en enable future growth some of the
areas this this would also address is
the grants life cycles for sub award
management centralized Grant data
management improved reporting and
Analysis we certainly would work better
together and off of spreadsheets
workflow automation enhance
collaboration integrate capabilities
and hopefully reduce some
findings our plan for implementation for
Grants management software would be
through because this is a new software
for the state would be through an RFI
process and then RFP we would utilize
the time in fiscal year 25 for the RFI
process and then move forward with an
RFP to
contract we did as a group look at um
potential
um available software that others are
using that would feed to um our federal
sources our grant funding sources that
are um that we work mostly with now for
FEMA and there are available options out
there project request five is
modernization of plate room production
equipment the equipment at the
Department of Corrections which
manufacturers are license plates is some
of that equipment is more than a hundred
years old and um really needs
replacement so we are looking we got
this estimate for from our current ven
vendor to update that equipment and um
and currently there are 91 different
plate types there are 12 steps in this
current process and of course you have
the manufacturing cost of each plate
um we would be looking our future state
is certainly to increase increase
production support the Department of
Correction mission statement and um
reduce the environmental impact
utilizing sustainable
Technologies I think with that kind of
brings us back certainly to from the
license plate to collecting for the road
tool um through the automated software
question thank you uh just for
clarification the on the the gun range
the gun range is an outdoor gun range
and the facility is is does not contain
a gun range in it it's just for
administrative classrooms and things
like that yes sir it's really it's a
piece of land off of exit 23 in New
Hampton and there's just a a stick frame
building with um plywood and a wall that
I think we built it in the early '90s
but there's no running water no
electricity it's generator there's no
bathroom so it's really like a it's like
an old shed do do the Troopers have any
indoor range that they can practice at
during the winter months or is it
strictly Outdoors it's all it's outdoors
that's that's all we do uh and this is a
a question sort of related to that but
not on your list here uh the current
sidearms of the Troopers uh are they
iron sighted or do they have they issued
Red Dot or lab they are they're issued
that
they they are issued that the sightings
iron SES yeah okay and then they have
the additional sites okay any any
thought about upgrading the sidearm or
is that's not well the sidearms are um
so yes they are the colonel and his
staff are looking at that and they
currently are those are toward life's
end and they're they're in process of
studying that and that would have to be
built into our operating budget so we
are having those discussions not for
Capital but for operating but it's it's
time and they've been looking at them
for
over over a year or so okay great thank
you that's it for
me good morning I have a question uh
surprisingly on the grants management
system um and Amy I don't know if you
can talk more on this but I um we just
did we well let me back up we have a
major contract with our current vendor
to upgrade our state Erp system which
includes a grants management component
and I know that we recently did a a
change order to add safety as the pilot
agency to go live with that Grant
Management module so I was just trying
to understand that relationship with
coming on board with the grant
management system that the state is
currently upgrading versus going out
with a new system and how that might
connect or not connect so I see them as
two different systems so this would this
system would focus primarily on
pre-award so what I've what I've learned
with pre-award and post award system is
they're generally separate systems so
because you wouldn't necessarily want
all applications to feed automatically
into your post- award compliance system
because not all of your applications are
going to be funded and that budget is
not going to that that is provided
federally is going to um feed into your
Finance system it's not going to be
approved as what's necessarily um uh
submitted
um federally they're going to make
tweaks and they're going to um edit they
might fund certain lines and not other
lines so you want you'd want to have
some manual process within that to then
feed into your Finance system so I think
there is some manual process in there
the only other thing I was going to say
is I know that um I know Dennis might be
able to talk more about it but our
Salesforce contract we currently use
them for a lot of that pre-award process
and um applications that we use
throughout sort of the here in arpa so I
don't know if you've looked at that
contract at all just to see if that
might be a solution also for you or if
you haven't maybe could connect on that
yeah I can I can comment on that I
actually I'm just messaging with Ron
Reed your it lead as as we're speaking
um so uh we're actually working gopher
is currently running Salesforce right
now it's an older version that they
actually created they worked with
Salesforce to create um early covid for
um for managing the cares act funds and
um so it's been running for years um
they're we've been speaking to them
about going to to the since then
Salesforce has created a commercial
offer shelf offer shelf version and we
have a number of agencies right now
looking at that so it's it's possible
we'll end up standardizing on that for
the state for the pre-award stuff so so
and we we can talk about that should the
funds get appropriated and and work with
you and I I'll you know I'll be
communicating with Ron as well that's
great thank you sir
yeah any other questions seeing none
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you for your
time like to invite up Department of
Environmental
Services need more
good morning commissioner good morning
uh again I'm for the record uh Bob Scott
the department environmental services I
have our chief operating officer Susan
Carlson with me uh so I so as you get
your your handouts uh on slide two uh
you'll see our total requests are for
$63
million um eight of the of of the eight
requests two are for Dam work uh three
related to matching funds for federal
programs and particularly the uh the the
bill uh infrastructure funds that we're
still getting uh in the match required
for that and the final three are for
ongoing capital projects that we're in
the middle of uh I'll I'll review each
uh in a little bit of detail uh moving
to slide three on the slide deck uh the
first request is for 10 projects at dams
either for the repair work of the dam
directly or for the design work to do
that repair work uh included in the list
of three projects for the Lakeport Dam
uh the import of that dam is Lake
Waki uh two projects are from Murphy Dam
in Pittsburgh that controls the
headwaters of the Connecticut River uh
in addition uh we also have two uh we're
calling them slope machines but for uh
maintenance uh of the
uh the uh the additional dams that we
have the
uh and then and then also uh there's
also embedded in that is generators for
the our new uh Dam facility at silk Farm
Road uh and then uh upgrades to the uh
skada or industrial control systems at
several of the Lakes uh to help with
automation not included in this but in a
in a on slide I think slide seven but
I'll talk to that and the IT portion of
our request is embedded uh our flood
monitoring Network upgrades so we can
help predict uh a little bit better
flooding to keep the dam safe and our
community so moving to slide
four uh we broken this out a little bit
different from the uh other Dam projects
these are four empowerments on pway Lake
which is State Park as you're probably
aware uh they're in poor condition in uh
becoming unstable and having seepage
issues uh given first at the state park
and given that for at least to to do
this work we're lowering Lake the the
water Body by almost 25 ft uh we want to
do all these at once uh so that way we
minimize the impact to the dncr for
revenues for our obviously for our
citizens for recreation so in this case
we it only makes sense to do these at
once that would allow us to uh basically
only have the uh the lake lowered that
much for one season and then have it
back on on track
again moving to uh slide five uh as many
of you are aware we've through the
infrastructure act we've received uh
extra money that lasts it's a 5-year
period it goes through Federal fiscal
year of 26 which greatly increased our
state revolving loan input uh the the
upshot of that is in the early years we
were required to do 10% match to get all
this extra money in the outer years
which we're now entering we're required
to match 20% to to receive this money so
this is this is what you're seeing in
slide five uh and again this would this
amount would allow us to get almost 27
million in federal
funds slide six is just a little bit
more detail on that and again again this
extra money as I call it uh gets us
through Federal fiscal year
26 uh which is obviously not the same as
our state fiscal year uh and then we'll
go back to more normal uh amounts that
traditional we have traditionally we
have seen uh which will obviously
therefore require less match moving
forward on slide
seven uh item number four is for super
Sun fund uh State match so in miramac uh
in 1992 neure plating was listed as a
superf fund site uh EPA did did remedial
action on that there's still issues not
completely addressed that particular
site does not have a responsible party
uh where we are right now in the the
sequence of things is additional money
going in the state to to remediate that
site requires a 10 10% State match uh
this money here the uh
$829,000 would leverage almost 13
million uh eventually in in Federal
money item number eight slide number six
is our groundwater well expansion so
many of you excuse me may remember not
well not last year uh this year but last
year and the two years before that we
went three years running in severe
drought for different parts of the State
uh that that helped us realize we need
to to be able to better monitor our
groundwater to be able to not only
predict but also understand the impacts
of these these type of things uh in the
last cycle we were able to fund uh 16 of
25 needed new new additional Wells along
with uh data loggers and Telemetry to go
along with those uh this request would
ask us would allow us to complete the
the rest of those uh in order to better
monitor those
activities slide seven which is uh
excuse me slide nine which is uh item
number seven uh it infr structure uh
we've been doing a lot of work uh on uh
working closely with doit on our e
permitting
uh uh Evolution for one of a better word
uh the the good and bad part is as we as
we evolve our customers uh at all levels
uh of the State uh depend on that that
being online whether it's e per meting
or just environmental D data so as we're
making good strides we're also need to
maintain our current system while we
develop and and move move forward so
some some uh so that's part of this
request also as I mentioned this
forecasting uh for flood emergencies uh
that system is embedded here also so and
then finally on slide 10 uh item number
eight is a request for the W Baki River
Basin so for background again for those
who haven't followed this uh this this
is a waste White facility in Franklin it
with collection uh systems in 10
communities uh ranging from Meredith uh
to Alton to lonia to Franklin
itself uh that's uh that is funded
entirely by user fees from those
communities so it's part of the part of
our capital budget request because we
own and operate the system or or the the
wastewater treatment facility but they
fund this this is not General funded uh
as with many of these type of systems uh
we are at the point now where lines are
breaking uh with fairly
regularity uh the the sewer Mains and
need to be replaced so we have uh a lot
of this is for sewer line Replacements
uh the communities again are supportive
expecting it and wanting this uh there's
really no choice that the obviously
replacing a line before it breaks and
doing it in a controll fashion is much
cheaper than doing many repairs as
things break uh
unexpectedly uh so so that's that's the
Crux of this but again if nothing else I
I I just want the committee to
understand that this is not capital
budget money excuse me it is capital
budget money but it's not general fund
money so with that we're very happy to
answer any questions I have uh our
directors R the back along with uh Corey
Clark who runs our dam program so if
there's any questions we're happy to
answer that great thank you so much uh
two-part question uh how many dams are
are under DS's perview and and how do
you rank them to or or do you rank them
to determine whether or not uh repairs
are needed is it is as simple as you
know red yellow green coating system or
something far more complicated than that
so Su is going to correct me if I get
the exact number wrong I want to say 276
dams is that correct 274 I was off by a
small percentage uh so those are State
on dams that thees is responsible for
for operation certainly M maintaining uh
and then we have roughly 10 times that
for private dams throughout the state
just to give you an order of magnitude
uh as far as how do they rank it's
really and you'll notice there's always
uh by the way so in our request for dams
we we typically will give here's the
dams we want to work on and then we
always have a a footnote saying
depending on needs so what you know for
instance if there's a sinkhole in front
of a dam that that suddenly develops in
the middle of the cycle
we we we want to fix that so nobody gets
hurt so to answer your question uh
director is um what we do is we look at
there's different categorizations
categorizations categorizations for dams
High Hazard dams are ones that are going
going to risk if they were to breach
risk uh life and property uh those are
the highest risk so we we we base our
priorities on that and then on condition
so we we kind of match the two so we
have a a conditioned Dam again something
with cracks in it or a sink hole in
front of it that's going to if it goes
will will take out houses or a bridge or
something like that that gets a higher
priority than a dam uh for instance uh
fish and game dams you know they're for
more for recreation dncr dams are more
for recreation they're they're perhaps
depending on the dam less likely to have
those type of impact so they're
important for recreation Etc but if
nobody's going to get hurt then they're
lower priority do you know how many dams
are in categorized as poor condition uh
I'm going to turn to Corey uh Clark here
so I don't know how we want to get him
up here let's just grab a
chair I told him to sit up front he was
trying not to but now he knows why so
for the record Corey Clark chief
engineer the Dan Bureau New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services so
we have um out of those um High Hazard
dams that uh commissioner Scott was
mentioning there's 64 High Hazard dams
that the state of New Hampshire is in
charge of out of the
274 mentioned earlier uh 34 of those are
in poor condition what we're finding is
that uh the number of dams in poor
condition is it has increased
um uh by over 50% in the past 10 to 20
years the reason of that is not that
we're building more dams that those dams
are falling into worse Condition it's
that the computer modeling and the
techniques used to analyze these dams is
getting better and better
so while the the structures themselves
may not be deteriorating rapidly or
anything it's the fact that we're
finding out that they don't have
adequate discharge capacity because of
the storm events that they're seeing
they they are unstable based on the
different computer modeling so um so the
numbers are coming higher and higher as
far as um that's what I know for the
high Hazard dams as far as being in poor
condition and going back to the ranking
um we certainly try to Target those
structures as the first ones and the
priority to uh to get
repaired thank you if I can put it in
another way a d Dam design 80 or 100
years ago was designed to different
safety safety standards than are are
today uh I will also I have sub the
representatives and Senators here um you
know we did ask last year and this is
going through so there there'll be a
legislative study committee to look at
generally how Dam should be funded
moving forward again that number of
dams um and yes we have a a fairly large
ask of I think 20.8 20.7 million for
this year is really not going to be an
aberration moving forward those are
those are the type of monies that are
going to be needed moving forward so
recognizing there's a lot of moving
parts to all this uh we've asked for a
study commiss committee uh to look at
how best to fund all this okay and and
just to to build upon that one of some
of the numbers that were mentioned in
those um hearings for those the study
committees was last year Dees looked at
what would it take to um bring the
entire inventory into compliance roughly
out of the 273 dams we looked at uh the
number was roughly $414 million to bring
all of those 273 dams into compliance
and just the 64 high-hazard dams would
be uh $300 million so those are some of
the numbers that we were discussing in
those those hearings
thank you any other um I know it's going
to seem like one damn thing after
another
um I couldn't resist so uh question and
it's sort of like the fishing game
question you you're you want to fix
houses where people stay overnight um
how many people do you have staying
overnight at your dams two so we have
two oh just two so we have uh we have I
mentioned Murphy Dam up in Pittsburgh
obviously it's kind of a hike from Ed uh
and uh so that is a dam where and the
reason why we have and the other one
real quickly is like Port Dam uh in
lonia uh and the reason why we have for
both those facilities we have a a
structure there where an employee stays
uh and the reason for that is if some
again it's very similar but for
different slightly different reasons
than Scott was mentioning if there's a
major issue with the dam we want
somebody to be able to react right to it
then and not take a couple hours to get
there and you know have bad things
happen and you know so so again those
are two important dams uh same kind of
thing though he lives there yes or she
lives there yeah correct um just out of
curiosity is that a job somebody hangs
on to for a
while like yes yeah I guess so yeah I
mean we had the one up in Pittsburgh
years ago retired out of that job um so
yes yeah it's just it's interesting it's
just um You Don't See a lot of that
anymore I ideally I would say especially
for Lon I'm still not sure we'd ever
want to do this for Pittsburgh given the
travel distance you know the more we get
comfortable upgrade the dam automated
enough so we can you know that's a
potential maybe one of those could go
away but so you're saying I shouldn't
apply you could be uh made OBS obsess
that's true of most of my jobs um the uh
the the uh Federal match uh the the
drinking water and the uh clean water
grants are those
scalable and that is to say if we if we
allocated more money could we have a
greater match we allocated less money or
is this say it's 9 million or
nothing um the match is dependent on
what the federal government gives us so
um right now we're not anticipating
receiving any more than we estimated we
may receive less but we won't know until
we get closer to those fisal years what
EPA will have for funding in order to
give us those grants so let me let me
reverse the question then too um let's
say the capital budget were tight um and
we and we looked at it and said well gez
we can't do nine we could do three is
that the kind of thing where the federal
government would say no it's nine or
nothing we could probably scale it down
but I would need to confirm with that
but understand too that we put in
Jeopardy um
The Loan program plus we put in Jeopardy
the Staffing that is funded by this loan
program so it might be scalable it might
be scalable more likely might be
scalable by year not by Dollar okay
thank you but again stating the obvious
you'd we're getting it's a 20% match so
we'd be giving up 80% Federal money no I
I mean there a lot of stuff like that
something's going to something's going
to not get funded that has a 70 or 80%
Federal match though
mine's a followup to commissioner Arley
house which was the if I'm reading this
correctly this is Page Six the
supplemental is that 47 million so the
additional 20% that we're we would be
responsible for that gets us that
additional 47 million is that how I
could read that yes that's correct I
mean this ask gets us 96.6 million in
federal funds in total in total correct
for both programs okay and so that's
supplemental why we the New Hampshire
could be awarded that we would be
responsible for a 20% match I think
that's where Charlie was going could we
get something less than 47 we would
still have to match whatever that number
is at 20% yes but is that something that
we might supplemental is pretty much a
set number it's the base that okay will
will be subject to change the
supplemental is funded through the bill
program so those numbers are pretty much
set okay now we may have ability if some
other state a year to down the road
decides not to take their supplemental
Grant we may get a reallocation and then
we have to have additional match but um
this is what we are assured of for
supplemental um requiring that
additional match I think that's aent is
if if the state could not fund that
additional 20% do we have an opportunity
to tell the Feds that or are we on the
hook for coming up with that
regardless is that what you so in other
words could we tell them we don't have
that extra 20% we can't it how would
that work if we decline the
grant um if we have no match for
supplemental then they take the money
and they reallocate it and then they
they would reallocate okay I'm not
saying that that's a good idea or not a
good idea I'm just looking at
mechanically how it would work okay
thank
you uh so staying with the clean
drinking water matching funds these are
for communities right um and Community
Water Systems to be able to upgrade
those systems is that right yes okay in
past
years um how much of the allocation has
been
unused very
little almost almost zero almost zero um
what we have only seen in the last two
years is um with the additional
supplemental um bill money some some
states have just not been able to handle
the capacity the additional money brings
and so have not been able to ask for
those Awards yeah I was thinking more
about the communities that use the
program do you ever have any money left
over I mean are there communities that
that don't use the money it it's over
subscribed pardon me it's over
subscribed not under subscribed there
you go okay thank you yeah gener
generally we um
every year we have so much money to loan
because this is a loan program I
understand um and generally the ask is
not quite a
9010 um but it's generally twice or
three times what we have available to Lo
and in many cases isn't it true that
communities wouldn't be able to go ahead
with the infrastructure Improvement
without this program absolutely yeah
they have the same issues I was talking
about for the W basaki River basin
you know again you could wait to the
water pipe to have a geyser on Main
Street but it's happening whether you
want to fund it or not is is the problem
they have so right so my other question
is um about P pway Lake dams what kind
of dams are
those you know
Cory so Cory Clark chief engineer the
dam Bureau so bway lake is formed by
four structures those structures were
originally built in the mid 1800s by the
new market manufacturing company to buy
water down to New Market and they are um
essentially each one there's just's two
dams and two dikes each one is uh a
double ston wall Granite Dam so they
built two Granite walls and infilled
that area with Earth and in some cases
buttress the downstream side um one of
the the biggest issues in the draw down
that commissioner Scott was mentioning
is doll Dam which is the biggest dam on
the lake um has a wooden gate at the
bottom that hasn't been re rehabilitated
um I think in over 40 years and so that
is the reason we have to draw it all the
way down in order to do the
rehabilitation project on that low-level
gate amongst many other upgrades at all
the structures thank
you any additional
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony
like to invite up now the New Hampshire
Veterans
[Music]
Home good
morning thank
you would you your microphone please oh
sorry thank you the record Kim McKay new
have your veterans
home I'm going to go ahead and start um
at uh the third page of the uh slide
deck just to talk about what the New
Hampshire veteran home is um in
1889 um the the development of the
veterans home started uh they developed
a prominent uh Board of managers and
they opened up 1890 so we've been there
for 134 years uh it was first open to
Civil War soldiers unable to care for
themselves in the last 134 years we've
had 11 commants um with many over 20
years the oversight of the uh New
Hampshire Veterans Home is the board of
managers which is made up of 12 members
who are appointed throughout the state
by the governor and confirmed by the
executive Council the commanders from
the American Legion the veteran service
I mean excuse me the Veterans of Foreign
Affair uh Foreign Wars and disabled
American veterans and nine citizens make
up the board two of those members are
New Hampshire veteran home residents and
the board has oversight of the operation
in the New Hampshire veterans home we
are long-term care facility we're
licensed for 22 uh 250 beds we are
budgeted for 225 and we are budgeted for
nearly 400 full-time staff members our
greatest challenge as many long-term
care in hospitals are seeing is actual
hiring of nurses and having uh the
nursing support needed so today we have
123 residents um with weight list of
about seven we have a couple of missions
admissions already planned off that
weight list and we are processing 40
applicants um as of today we utilize the
Veterans Affair VA Grant Program under
uh 38 CF R
5141 which allows us to have either uh
full payment of their care or partial
payment of their care uh there's two
different levels of uh payment the
mission of the New Hampshire Veterans
Home is to provide the best quality of
life for New Hampshire veterans with
dignity honor and respect and I think
the staff do that each and every day um
our strategic infrastructure priorities
are always veterans health health and
life safety to meet the ADA requirements
to meet infection and prevention
controls and to meet the VA laws and
Survey requirements which are
extensive our current projects that we
have right now are the Statewide
drainage and water life safety
improvements which is underway our entry
Life Safety improvements which is also
pending our medical installation phase
two has been completed and the Veterans
Home Building addition uh otherwise
known as lid you addition is in process
and I just want to pause to thank Ted
copper and Das because they have done an
immense amount of work to get a VA
project uh timeline met and our parking
lot repair and ex uh expansion was just
approved last week so we are moving
forward with that so for the future
projects um of course we came up with a
lot more than this uh the few that we're
presenting to you today uh but we
streamlined that knowing there's a limit
here the one that just uh entered the
list on the top and as you can app
appreciate right now with the weather is
our rooftop and Air Handlers on our Leo
building which is about 22 years old 22
years old is actually the roof uh top
Air Handlers are no longer functioning
um so today right now we are cooling
those 100 uh bed areas with heat pumps
from our hallway there is no air uh in
their bedrooms and I think we're going
to have a challenge the next couple days
to keep doing that we have a temporary
fix that we've worked with Department of
Public Works to to get some blowers in
there um but we are putting this on the
request for a long-term fix so we have a
temporary fix of replacing Motors but we
need to fix the whole unit all three
units we have a diesel tank removal
request uh replacing um some tubs and
bar and adding a bariatric tub shower uh
elevator repairs bet veteran bed and
mattress repairs or replacement excuse
me and updating tar North areas and the
medical lift so I'll go right into it I
think pictures uh can describe it much
more than I can but these are the air
handlers and as you can see these three
uh resident neighborhoods that serve
over 100 Veterans are over 30 years old
um well are they 30 or they 22 they were
up there 22 years old yeah sorry there's
a typo here um and due to their age and
they're they're just Obsolete and we
can't repair them we have made attempts
to repair them we hired a welder they
came and made some repairs that bought
us a little bit of time about a month
and then due to the loss of Integrity of
the metal Parts as soon as the unit
started shaking they would crack and
break so you can see here due to
vibrations these are
broken um and they need to be
replaced the second uh Capital request
we are asking for is an underground
diesel tank removal so the underground
tank that we have is 12,000 gallons and
that used to uh feed all of our boilers
within the buildings and uh we did
transfer over to natural gas with the
exception of our emergency generator um
needing that uh Diesel and so right now
the diesel tank is quite a distance as
you can see on the map here to the
generator so it travels quite a distance
and we with us um we need to test it and
do a backup generator that that is 100
KW generator to provide the required 96
continuous hours of a power load um and
we had that would just take under 500
gallons of fuel but so this is just an
Overkill tank now it's just so much fuel
and unfortunately what happens is diesel
not used after a while ages out and then
you have to pump it out and it becomes
even more costly because now we have to
dispose of this aged Fuel and we are on
on that line we're getting pretty close
to that being uh too old so we would
like to try to get a smaller tank that
was closer to the emergency generator to
use that instead um and that tank would
not be buried in the ground so we would
get out of the ground um the third
requests we have here are seven tubs and
one bariatric stretcher shower trolley
um what has happened is our tubs and
those are crucial obviously to provide
care for our residents they're just
aging out and um we're not able to get
the parts any longer so in areas that
we're not using due to a lack of Staff
we have closed some of our units we are
now taking parts from them to fix the
tubs in the areas of residents are using
our goal is not to keep those units
closed we want to provide care to all of
the veterans in the state of New
Hampshire that want to come to us and so
we're working on our staffing increasing
but we also will be stuck now because
we've taken Parts out of tubs and we
we'll have difficulty getting in back
into those units so um we are asking to
replace the seven tubs and add a
bariatric stresser uh trolley to that
you can see the picture on page 14 that
allows people who are unable to um get
up into a chair and into a tub to still
be bathe and have um uh tub baths if
they would like and uh so the goal would
be to try to assist them and also lower
the risk of Staff
injuries number four is replacing one of
our elevator and updating the other two
elevators um obviously the elevators are
the way that that our veterans get in
and out of the facility it's how we get
a lot of our Goods up into the facility
and so with having elevators not in
working order um and we have a couple
staff member who have members who have
been stuck in an elevator so they would
love to testify that they never want
that to happen again uh having to be
pulled out from the fire department was
not enjoyable uh one of our elevators is
actually not operating at all so we've
had to close it and then the other ones
we'd say they're they're down about 10%
of the time where we have to get the
company to come in and replace it the
company is now um using oldest El
Elevator Parts that they got from U
replacement elevators they know our
elevators are so old that they're
keeping those to try to replace ours and
carry them along a useful life of
elevator is estimated between 20 and 25
years and some of our elevators are 48
years old so they have well ped their
age um benefits obviously we would use
less energy they would reduce the
shutdowns in the service calls we spend
quite a bit on service calls they
improved the safety and uh the new
elevators allow you to have um something
called Max link connected so we can uh
get emergency uh calls out much quicker
we video we can text um and so we're
asking to replace in update to uh
replace the resident beds so the
replacement of the beds is come really
about because a lot of all of our beds
have a middle and try I'm like a hands
first sorry um a uh locking breake in
the middle of the bed and the nurse for
the LNA has to use their knee to lock it
in place unlike if you go to a hospital
it's usually foot you just step down and
it locks the bed um this has resulted in
nursing injuries in uh compensation
worker compensation claims over
$250,000 and several hours of time loss
so then that doesn't in incorporate our
overtime when we have to backfill those
positions because people are out so we
want to replace the beds with a foot
breaks so we can promote safety and
reduce those injuries and then on top of
that we always need to uh update
mattresses mattresses only have a 5year
span lifespan so we need to update them
and our goal is to update them every two
years 50 at a time so we're working
through the budget that
way uh number six is our biggest ask um
and I believe it was here last year as
well our last budget uh this goes along
with the ADA requirements and
IPC uh infection prevention control our
doors are not wide enough so there are
some wheelchairs that are uh larger due
to bariatric residence that can't fit in
our rooms so we have
to decide where they're going to live in
our building based on the rooms and what
they have for adaptive equipment so
right now uh each room is required to be
48 in on the door to the bedroom and uh
our current ba uh bedroom doors are 42
in and the bathroom doors are even
smaller they're 36 in so they're really
really small um so we need to update our
doorways uh we also need to move away
from having four people two in one room
two in another with an on a joining
bathroom four veterans are using one
bathroom and that is not a pleasant
experience they they do not like doing
that and I don't blame them um and then
if you look at the next uh slide on 19
you'll see our floors are buckling
uh this is a shower which is a real
issue for tripping hazards and so the
showers need to be replaced the doors
need to be
replaced uh in the on page
20 the showers have to be for the VA
requirements which who is who licensed
us so we can get the VA payments they
have to be 48 in wide and they also have
to have a seat inside them and you can
see from this picture this is built
years and years ago this is on our older
side the chair the seat is outside the
shower and I'm guessing that the goal
was for them to get dressed there but it
doesn't help somebody who needs to have
the shower chair inside the shower and
then we also have lots of built-in
furniture that was there and as you can
see from these pictures they are broken
um they we've taken off closet doors
because they have fallen down and we
don't want to the residents to be harmed
um on tar South it is so bad over there
that we've actually moved our residents
off that unit and moved them to um one
of the older Memory Care units because
we had to close that down due to staff
and that's where they're living because
we can't we just don't feel that is safe
for them to be there any
longer and the last one uh we are asking
for is the continuation this would be
phase three of installing medical lifts
so that we can move patients or
residents from their chair to their bed
or throughout the room room uh the goal
is to get 20 more to do that uh this is
if anybody's seen the old Hoyer lifts
that you would wheel into a room you
would try to get the resident in there
and then you wheel them it feels very
unsafe for them but it also um we see a
lot of back injuries with our staff
because of that this system is over the
bed and uh has a sling system similar to
that but you lower it you can lift the
resident and you can move them safely uh
more securely and really they feel
better about
that uh we will be lapsing we're going
to extend to have some uh lapse
extensions uh requests here one like we
talked about was the drainage is
underway the life safety is under way we
would do we would uh continue to do the
building project with the VA and the
parking lot so we would be asking for
those extensions as
well thank you thank you uh
the generator I know you you want to
replace the the fuel tank for the
generator it's a diesel fuel tank what's
the condition of the
generator theor can you turn your
microphone please thank you the
generator is actually in really good
condition so I actually applied for a
grant to replace it with a natural gas
generator and when they came and looked
at it they said that that thing's
basically brand new we're not going to
give you any money for that so we're
we're and until we can get to the point
where we can add it to natural gas we're
just looking to replace the tank okay
thought it had a bright idea there but I
guess it's very very
long okay thank
you any other questions I'm curious how
many of your patients are are bariatric
patients oh boy I would say probably
five residents right now are bariatric
in the sense
that there's a lot of residents that are
uh obese So when you say bariatric I'm
thinking like three four or five um
probably like four or five of them okay
I'm just curious and our new our new um
building that we're building will
actually have 10 bariatric rooms that's
part of our uh the new addition that uh
we're not extending bed size we're just
taking some of those shared rooms and
moving into the private uh Wing that we
hope will be built in
2026 right I look at Ted because his
team is helping Shepherd it through and
I'm then I'm sure it will
yes um my question is just on more of
the federal funding so you receive
federal funding you talked about for you
know the care of the residents is there
any other programs either through the VA
or through other Federal avenues that
can help with more of the equipment side
of the house or some of the the
construction side no they can do
construction um like we are doing this
project that has been underway since I
think it began uh with this process in
2016 and so there is a process but it's
very long and um you so we could ask for
um like a warehouse and I think in the
past they have asked for a warehouse
then the VA will come and say no you
don't qualify because your Warehouse is
actually big enough for your square
footage from their regulations if it's
something that they would qualify for
the state matches uh 35% and they do 65
but it's I would say years to get
something into actual and those
definitely sound like more um I'll say
construction type they're more
construction to I'm thinking the beds
the lifts the more of that equipment
side that they is there anything
available for that no
okay it's a good thought
though you talked about the generator
can you convert the
generator to natural gas so yes we can
so we looked into that um and we can
we're certainly looking to adding the
gas line to where it needs to go um but
we're not at that point yet so I I kind
of kicked the tires on it and and I was
kind of shot down initially so I lost a
little hope in it so the the easy answer
would be to just get rid of the big tank
and put a smaller tank in its place for
now until we can get to natural gas so
the generator we have we we would
actually need to replace the generator
that then when they came to look at it
there's no conversion kit for the
generator that we have in
place see another other questions thank
you very much for your
testimony I'd like to invite up now
military Affairs and veteran services
please good
morning uh good morning uh Mr chair
committee members for the record I'm
David meltis uh Commissioner of
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services is AG General New
Hampshire National Guard I'm joined
today by Major Matt Henry uh our deputy
director of construction and Facilities
maintenance so let's talk like three big
things or broad categories before we
start looking at our specific requests
uh number one is um the size of our
infrastructure and how much square
footage that the National Garden the
department of military Affairs manages
conceptually speaking we have over 50
buildings exceeding a million square ft
of office space in 177 communities
throughout the state so we have a
significant portfolio across the state
of infrastructure your number two is um
when you look at the data from the other
departments we're the number three in
the state for bringing federal funds
bringing those federal funds is
predicated on the fact that we have to
have a state match generally speaking
the state match is three broad
categories 100% federal funds which is
typically for our maintenance facilities
like vehicle maintenance helicopter
maintenance 7525 federal state cost
share is generally for new military
construction and then 50 50 50% Federal
50% state is for the general upkeep and
maintenance of our 18 armories that
exceed 350,000 sare ft so those are big
prod categories and the last thing I'd
like to talk about too is um leveraging
those federal funds so generally
speaking when we get military
construction dollars um we compete
nationally against the other 53 States
territories in District of Colombia
through a a pretty competitive process
that either says one or two things our
facili our facilities are either Legacy
structures that are under sized or
they're poor condition and our ability
to use that process through Congress to
get these larger or midsize projects is
a big deal getting that state match
matters because we've competed Nally for
these projects so we submitted nine
projects I'm going to talk about the
first six and we have an additional one
I'd like to bring to your attention um
the first project is the Milford
Readiness Center addition
alteration congressionally approve
National Guard Bureau funded addition to
our Milford Armory um which houses our
Mountain infantry unit you we did
addition about five years ago it's still
under size we still need to build a
bigger addition because the unit has
significantly more
equipment number two is Manchester land
replacement it remains a state priority
for us to get out of the Manchester
Armory if that is to Ur we need State
money to buy land to start the process
for that divesture we asked in the last
bium it wasn't approved we we asked for
it
again number three is What's called the
Plymouth read Center addition alteration
um this was a congressionally directed
spending a project that was approved by
Congress that is part of the Manchester
divesture which allows us to move
another unit out of Manchester into
pemr project number four Statewide ready
a center roof
Replacements asset manage Asset
Management right we have a huge
portfolio of armories um we just got to
do roof Replacements it's no more no
less it's not it's not attractive but
it's just uh keeping your house in order
number five Training land Road Trail
maintenance um our soldiers got a train
whether it's walking through the woods
walking on a trail or driving a truck
through the woods we need sort of a
trail Improvement system to allow our
soldiers to either like uh walk through
the woods um and do different
activities I number six Aviation hanger
Edition um we've been our number one
party for the Army guard for the about
past four to five years is to get new
helicopters we did it uh we get two new
helicopters they're called a uh utility
helicopter 72 Alpha a Lota the first one
sitting on the tarmac over there guess
what we don't have hanger space to put
it in um so we want to build an addition
we leverage our Congressional Delegation
100% further reimburse the storage of
those two
helicopters and the seventh priority
which is not on your list which we gave
you additional piece of paper for was um
it's called the Plymouth Readiness
Center addition um let me rephrase that
the Plymouth Readiness Center additional
design and construction funds in the
last bium we requested $29
million we are approved for 25 million
um we want to insert the additional $4
million to bring it up to the full
Congressional appropriation
why construction cost have increase we
need the money to build a full
requirement we have only Built one new
Armory in the state of New Hampshire
that's a standalone facility in the last
20 years um this is a huge deal to give
us a full authorization for that
facility and uh we seek your approval
for that 7525 cost year subject to your
questions that's all I
have thank you uh I was wonder if you
could
explain a brief overview on on actually
how the federal funding works because I
I noticed like in the Milford Readiness
Center Edition it's a million dollars of
general fund supplemented by 3 million
of federal funds so it's a three to1
match whereas this the Statewide
Readiness roof Replacements looks to be
a Ono one match what what's the
difference and how does a project get
more Federal funding as opposed to
less generally speaking all of our
armories on state are on state land we
only have one that's not so generally
speaking if it's on state land it
dictates the cost
share to sustain a building to roof
placement boiler replacement it's a 5050
cost share when you build new that cost
share changes to
7525 and again maintenance facilities
like our hangers our vehicle maintenance
shops they're all 100% fly reimbursed
thank you
sir any other
questions I just had one this on um
priority three which was the pem
Readiness Center yes um and you it looks
like on this one you had requested a
waiver of the state match and I was just
wondering how that process works and
what's the likelihood that that waver
would be approved or maybe it already is
approved
it it was included in the Senate armed
service committee markups we will tell
you in 6 months if we were successful
right so it this congressionally
directed spending projects are
relatively new Congress started doing
them 3 years ago we've got I think three
projects in FY 23 four projects in 24
this is one of the projects we're
competing in federal fiscal year
25 we finally realized there's a process
to ask for a uh State match waiver so
this is our first time trying it and we
hope to be successful and we can tell
you proba the answer in about six months
unless there's a continued resolution
okay and if this um is not if the waiver
isn't approved it um is this what is
this fall into du oh no we'll be coming
back to bra or 5050 or what would it'll
be a 7525 C sh okay thank
you so any know other questions thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you thank
you and to conclude the capital budget
hearings I'd like to invite up the
Department of Transportation
good
morning good morning thank you for
having us let's wait till the things get
handed out
please
begin a
set good uh thank you good morning
everyone uh my name is Bill Cass
commissioner for the dot with me today I
have uh assistant commissioner um Andre
Grier who will assist with some of the
um presentation on elements in his
Division and Director of Finance um
Danielle Shandra who will help explain
some of the other um financial
implications um as well so um a quick
overview on the first first slide um we
typically break our capital budget
present uh request into um into two
categories to align with departmental
funds generally in the highway fund
which deals with facilities and the
operational needs and general fund which
deals with um Aeronautics Rail and
Transit needs uh so we well we have
provided you know a com a single list of
of priorities uh we do tend to uh look
at uh priorities by by uh by by fund
and then this year's uh request uh the
highway fund uh request represents 10
projects totaling about $25 million and
a general fund request for seven
projects totaling about $13 million and
the types of requests um are are are a
little bit varied but um generally they
fall into uh categories of of recurring
uh established program matches um we'll
cover that a lot of that is uh um
historically matching um providing some
State funds to match the the federal
funds for Aeronautics uh Rail and
Transit um facility Investments as
stewards of the state assets a lot of
these are you know programmatic or
systematic as we continue to um maintain
our infrastructure to do our business um
but some are in this request are new new
requests for long deferred maintenance
um uh elements that uh just continue to
deteriorate without any way of
addressing them and then um one of the
other categories of requests is a couple
requests we have in here for replacement
of Legacy systems um that really don't
fit within our operational
needs uh and our growing liability as
those Legacy systems um age out so we'll
get into a little bit of the details of
that slide two uh or three I guess uh I
just wanted to give you an overview of
the department
um scope of
operations uh in in context with this
capital budget request so we manage well
over 400 structures across the state um
you know valued at an original cost of
over $90 million and just to give some
com some context uh you know we maintain
86 Patrol
facilities um typically with additions
uh across the state each facility
usually consists of of a patrol shed at
least one salt shed one sand shed and
other uh storage sheds at each facility
um in addition to the overall uh Highway
Maintenance Patrol sheds we maintain six
district offices six satellite garages
14 uh Bridge crew uh Bridge crew
quarters and most of our um this this
logistical distribution is set up to
meet our logistical needs primarily for
winter maintenance so um having material
storage and a reasonable number of
highway miles that are that are
maintained um in those regional and
local uh Patrol
sheds um additionally and we have some
requests here uh New Hampshire dot
maintains the state uh fuel distribution
um system so we have over 126 fuel tanks
uh and 450 miles of railroad tracks that
that we maintain and we support 11 local
public transit agencies
uh we run the Boston Express uh system
in the i93 corridor and we also support
12 federally funded airports so our
capital budget requests you know kind
of refer to this overall
scope um with that briefly i' I'd ask uh
Danielle to just discuss a little bit
about the two um uh sources of funds and
how we prioritize within those funds so
Danielle sure so so so on this slide we
have um the general funded priorities
and the highway funded priorities and we
split them up because the funding is
separate the highway fund priorities are
tied we we are tied to the State
Constitution Article 6A on the use of uh
revenues and for highways only for
public highways so the items that are on
the right hand side would fall under
that the items on the leftand side would
not so the Aeronautics uh Rail and
Transit um projects would not fun fall
under that and would need to be General
funded and so we have prioritized them
separately here although we are going to
follow the combined list that you
have very good so the next the next two
slides uh uh you know summarize the
combined list and the priorities uh
established by the department for the
combined um for the compined list so
moving on to slide seven and I'll try to
go through these in in in respect of the
committee's time pretty pretty quickly
but if there are any questions on
specific priorities as we go through it
um please please stop and ask so our
number one priority our first priority
is uh continued replacement of sand and
uh salt storage facilities this is a
programmatic or a systematic um uh
project uh we label it uh as a Statewide
project and instead of towards specific
um salt sheds um we've listed there for
your information some of the priorities
that we put this funding to but
typically every capital budget we ask
for a um for um uh the Statewide funding
to continue a uh systematic uh
replacement of our of our sand and salt
sheds and this this funding of about $3
million would um uh typically allows to
replace up to uh two uh sand salt shed
uh facilities recent bids on some recent
projects that we're doing this year um
in Bristol and Orford have been um about
$1.5 million each for um the full full
replacement we are typically using a
high arch gam roll design if you look at
any of our newer
facilities um and a big part of this is
um you know many of our sand and salt
sheds were built in the 70s and 880s
they're showing uh where and um having
the ability to store an ample amount of
material you know helps us be efficient
uh in terms of cost savings to buy in
bulk as well as to um reduce um
transport between sheds as well as to
hedge against um um you know supply
chain issues which we have experienced
in past years
um priority number two is uh fairly
similar it's a systemic or programmatic
uh kind of a investment to uh
continue uh addressing as many needs as
we can with um replacement and upgrading
of our underground fuel storage tanks uh
currently we have about 47 of the 126
that are over 20 years um about 39 that
are over 30 years old
um and uh once we get beyond that
20-year time frame some of the warranty
periods uh expire and they come with a
growing and increased risk of leakage
and
environmental impacts so
um again this we we have found recent um
fuel storage uh facility
Replacements Uh current projects have
run about
$800 um ,000 so this would uh try to get
at um a couple uh uh a couple of the
most highest needs in terms of um fuel
tank Replacements and keeping up with
those
needs priority number three on slide
nine um uh is again another uh
continuation of Prior
Investments
uh and and and looking to address Patrol
uh Patrol shed and facility Life Safety
upgrades um for a number of years we
have had
um um uh State Fire Marshall inspections
uh and and U violations for compliance
with uh a number of our operational
facilities and we continue to try to um
address those um violations some of
those things involve things like SE
segregation of internal and external
furnace rooms uh construction of
compliant rest facilities for staff
during winter maintenance
operations uh rewiring new wiring for
compliance with exit signs and emergency
lighting and things like that many of
our facilities um have been built were
built before current building code so um
trying to keep up uh and keep them safe
um this um ongoing like I said
programmatic uh systematic uh project or
funding uh allows us to continue to
address those those um those needs
um and at least you know from from those
inspections about 80% over 80% of our
Patrol facilities P at least one of the
uh mentioned violations um many are
cited for for for multiple violations so
um it is a need that that we do try to
keep up with and try to keep our um
Personnel in those facilities as safe as
possible priority number four uh deals
with the a targeted replacement of our
highest Patrol our highest priority um
patrol shed um uh and and a facility
replacement for the lempster ps215
patrol shed an estimated cost of uh 3.5
million um again it's somewhat
programmatic or systematic uh but um
this is targeted specifically to this uh
very outdated facility um the core of
this facility is a is a quanset hunt
that was previously used for military
exercises in
1940s um it was moved to the site um
urban legend that our staff has it
either came from um odion's point and Ry
it came from Mount Washington but uh and
and we've tried to keep it up for a
number of years uh there's been you know
out exterior Shell built around it and
extensions put on um but it is a extreme
L dated facility um uh the district
engineer wanted to do some further
improvements and add-ons but uh we felt
it was just a uh not a good uh
investment to continue and that we
needed to um replace this facility the
facility also also floods it has
standing water and puddles in the in the
um in the uh uh concrete floor in the
spring melt uh and it has multiple um
building code violations and things like
that so it is a uh is really one of our
oldest outdated currently our old oldest
outdated Patrol sheds that needs to be
replaced and typically in our capital
budget we try to replace uh one or two
um uh or secure funding to replace one
or two petrol sheds per cycle um ideally
with roughly 86 uh Patrol sheds uh
Statewide in a um I you know a design
life of around 50 years you know we
would be um we would replace we would
replace be replacing um you know several
several of those a year the rate we're
doing if we try to get one or two per
cycle we're we're we're on a track of
replacing them about every hundred years
which is not um which is not ideal but
um it is a sustained and systemic
investment to try to knock off the
highest priority every every um every
bium um similarly priority number five
uh deals with the roof replacement at
the Twin Mountain uh satellite garage
for about $1.2
million
um this is an older outdated um facility
the roof was never built structurally to
support snow loads it was
built excuse me in the late 60s when the
um
the thoughts at the time were to heat
heat the building to to melt the snow
off the roof and henceforth didn't need
the necessary um uh structural
requirements to to support the snow
loads but that's you know the energy
costs associated with that are very um
outdated um and the current roof is um
you know really subject to a lot of heat
loss and
inefficiency so um that is uh a priority
that we would um very much like to uh
address as
well our number six priority deals with
the federal Billing System I'll let
Danielle speak to that um a little bit
within her Bailey Wick y for your for
your um consideration we are asking to
replace the federal Billing System that
we use to Bill all of our federal
billing through
fhwa currently that um system is built
in Visual Basic which is no longer
really supported and the experts that
we've had over the years are retiring
and there is nobody else really to to
kind of do that um that system has had
multiple um upgrades and the programming
for that is done it's at end of life new
new programs uh new programming updates
that are put in there usually tend to
cause something else to fail we have
several portions of that that are
failing currently and it can only be
used for the most basic um funding
splits like 8020 so 80 federal state
match of 20 90 federal state match of 10
any of the more complicated um
combinations can't be done through that
so they're being done um manually and
the billing has to be has to go through
a real rigorous process to make sure
it's correct prior prior to going uh the
volume on that is about 700 active
projects and we have about $800 million
that actually flows through that system
system so we're asking for um the
funding to be able to do this not
internally we'd like it to go external
with a company that that can actually do
the upgrades on a regular basis that we
don't do and maintain the regulations
for um
fhwa great thank
you um priority 7 deals with uh facility
replacement another old Patrol shed in
uh the Twin Mountain uh area um this is
a uh facility that was condemned and
closed in
2011 um we have uh tried for the last 10
years to uh do without it but it is a
very Hub area at Twin Mountain in in the
North Country uh we have a salt shed uh
on on the site that is that is that is
strategic to the maintenance along Route
302 uh there's a satellite garage uh uh
up theill Hill there's a a fuel station
there that uh is used by State Police
and every everybody it's a hub there so
um while we have tried to do without
this facility uh we have found that over
the last 10 years we still need and uh
have maintained a presence there we've
maintained the presence through um you
know a series of of rented construction
trailers um without facilities and um it
has been um really a a challenge uh for
our folks and it's really just not a a
good um a good situation to have our
Personnel you know continuing to be
housed in temporary rented trailers you
know without without facilities and
things like that so um one of the asks
this year is is is uh to seek to fund a
uh replacement facility at the Twin
Mountain um location this would be a
multi-divisional uh facility that would
support not only the Highway Maintenance
folks but the regional um regional
bridge inspectors Regional construction
Personnel um that would that have and
continue to work out of that out of that
site so that's our number seven
priority um our number eight priority is
a number is is also an additional um uh
Legacy system that I'll ask Andre Brier
would speak
to good morning I'll attempt to side
saddle here uh this request is to engage
a consultant to begin the planning
process for transition from our project
development software the original code
was written in
2014 um it's with a company called
exhivision unfortunately there's not
offthe shelf software that that handles
the bids and the management of um
projects this is uh right now Services
over 1,700 contractors and
subcontractors along with our
Construction program um any there are
some off-the-shelf providers but it's
always um going to require customization
every state is in the same boat on this
so the highly customized nature of the
software uh does require the securing of
a consultant contract to manage the
transition it's a multi-year acquisition
multi-year transition from a piece of
software this importance and size really
no fail um as far as Federal compliance
managing all those federal dollars that
come into the state um so that's the
request is for
$500,000 to engage a consultant for the
planning and procurement uh of a
replacement system this current system
we have um the contract expires at the
end of 2026 there are extensions
available but our anticipation is even
if those extension options are exercised
we need to begin the planning process
now um for this type of system
priority nine is the replacement of uh
rail um and what this really is is the
purchase of four track miles of
115b rail and the the uh I mentioned
that because it is a different weight
and type of rail than is commonly
installed on our railroads today most of
our rail is over 100 years old and is
what's called 85lb rail that 85lb rail
was
um was rolled they say when you when you
construct this rail using a process from
the 1930s and 40s uh typically which did
not have controlled cooling it makes it
more susceptible to unpredictable brakes
a lot of the derailments you hear about
the country uh have to do with uh old
85lb rail it's not even made anymore not
commonly um accessible so this plan
would uh secure us just the four lane
the four ra track miles of rail of 115lb
rail that we would use to repair and
replace um broken outdated um or damaged
a old 85lb rail we will Salvage the uh
85lb rail that we find uh passes
inspection and utilize that as well but
with over 450 track miles um just
maintaining our rail to an acceptable
and safe condition requires this
acquisition um so that that rail can be
replaced as needs be really the same
story here with priority 10 this is a
replacement of railroad ties most of
these ties were installed in the 1920s
30s and 40s making uh the bulk of it
over a 100 years old well past useful
life again the danger of not replacing
uh these ties in a timely manner um
especially those that have disintegrated
you can see the pictures there of of
many of these ties that have
disintegrated is either closure of track
segments or unpredictable and very
undesirable accidents um so this again
would get us about 16,000 ties at the
low low price of $68 each which is
actually pretty much a bargain uh so
this is again necessary for the
maintenance of our active rail
track priority 11 uh is again kind of a
a similar story this is the right of way
system software replacement of $2
million the current systems 20 years old
again built in Visual Basic um Beyond
useful life um what we're finding on
some of these systems that um you know
as Danielle mentioned when you when you
implement upgrades um number one the
skill set of people that are familiar in
the programming language is becoming
sparse number two tends to crash
unintended parts of the system and um
it's requiring us to go back to
pre-digital processes just to maintain
um our book of real estate in this case
over uh worth over 450 million uh in
assets so this is a 2 million ask it's a
very small ask to manage a very large
portfolio of real
property number 12 is uh as the
commissioner said this is recurring this
is our normal budget item uh for State
match for FAA projects 4 milon uh
$714 uh in change to access 63 million
in FAA improvements and uh iiga funded
opportunities you can see the federally
eligible airports there that are part of
this system we we engage with Master
planning processes with all of these
airports those uh
requested um upgrades or maintenance is
then prioritized with the FAA we access
those FAA dollars through this program
priority 13 is Transit vehicle match
it's a
$390,000 request to access uh four over
$4 million in FTA funding opportunities
for ada8 compliant Transit vehicles um
we match the lesser of 10% or half of
the required state and local match FAA
covers between 80 and 85% 85% for 8A
Vehicles 80% for other
vehicles um and this would enable us to
continue uh maintaining and
recapitalizing that
Fleet Priority 14 is also an FDA program
but this has to do with um facilities so
you can see those three facilities on
the slide Coast uh down in the Sea Coast
Area Manchester transit authority and
advanced Transit bus storage facility um
all require um facility um mod
appications or upgrades most of those
are for safety reasons inspections and
things like that and uh small
administrative facilities that are
usually attached to
those priority 15 is priority 15 but it
it is a a very
glaring um problem uh that we have
because all the transit modes you've
heard about today highways airports rail
Transit um all have their own funding
streams all have a federal agency that
provides monies um unfortunately our
rail Trails rail trails are popular
Nationwide they're certainly very
popular in our state it's a good use of
abandoned rail corridors for recreation
and they are a business generator in our
state we get money part of the 10year
plan to construct rail trails and and
build these facilities there is no
funding stream federal or state to
maintain these trails and these Trails
uh which also Encompass old railroad
Bridges culverts all of which fail um
when they fail we are restricted as a
department from using Highway funds to
fix
them therefore when they go out of
commission they are just out of
commission so a community that may have
been very excited about getting a new
rail trail after a major rain event like
we've had a couple over this winter uh
can find themselves U again without a
usable Trail um we strongly urge funding
of a very modest
$600,000 to provide for the um for the
critical repairs to um either washed out
Trails failed um uh Bridges or culs it's
it's much needed and there are multiple
trails in our state right now that we
spend a lot of money and effort building
that are out of commission because of
this reason we have no funding uh stream
uh we partner with the Department of
Natural cultural resources to manage
these Trails even though most of the
time it's it's dot that's the underlying
real property owner um they also don't
have a funding stream to maintain these
Trails so sometimes we get lucky when a
community is able to fix a wash out but
when you're talking about a bridge or
cul structure there's not too many
communities around our state that have
the independent ability to fix
those that's my strong pitch for number
15 even though over during the end and
for 16 uh is uh emergency uh response
mobile command vehicle what this really
though is is just just like I I just
referenced um the
multiple natural disasters in our state
uh we're our state is becoming more and
more reliant on uas and that's the
drones um to rapidly inspect and um Aid
in the repair of uh either washing outs
Road failures natural disasters our
Bureau of Aeronautics Rail and Transit
is the one who responds to that and
provides those uh those aerial resources
this van would enable that group to get
closer and operate continuously out of a
location not have to come back to
headquarters to either download data or
recharge those systems it enables a
forward presence that lets us be more
responsive uh in a natural disaster
emergency and for 16 I'll pass it back
to commissioner
Cass and yeah final uh priority 17 is
another facility replacement so this
would represent the third Patrol shed
that's on the on the list uh it's down
toward toward the end uh this is the
Pinkham Notch uh Patrol shed which again
is
um uh very dated the existing facility
over 90 years old um really trying to
cram uh the the truck in in there and um
uh has a failed septic system and a
number of number of problems so it is
number uh
17 and and whether this can be fully
funded at least we put this on the list
to begin um even even some funding for
beginning uh design and looking at the
uh the the true needs um and true costs
for that facility replacement so um
hopefully we haven't over over over
overdone our time the last slide uh just
have have asked Danielle to speak to the
um uh you know The Debt Service
implications of this request so right so
so as you know treasury is responsible
for generating uh the general obligation
bonds uh on behalf of the these requests
um and the repayment of the bond debt
for Highway funded projects anyway is
done through the operating budget
and it's based on a 20-year repayment
schedule 5% interest with 60% of that
principal paid uh within the first 10
years so those are the implications
there so entertain any questions I
appreciate your um attention and um um
listening to our presentation thank you
thank you um I know the the the 10-year
plan just passed by the legislature as
want you tell me the relationship
between the capital budget and the
10-year plan are all some or none of
these projects located within the 10year
plan or what's the relationship between
the two none of these projects are are
contained within the 10year plan because
they really result they really um well I
I take that back a minute um most of
these projects are not are not tied to
the tene plan they deal with our uh
operational needs the exception to that
would be the um FAA match in the FTA
match so the federal funding for those
programs is um listed and contained in
the in the ten year plan uh and the
state match that's reflected in this
capital budget request is also reflected
in that uh 10-year plan but the other
facilities Investments and uh the Legacy
system Replacements um because they're
operational needs and and none of them
are um are
um eligible for for federal funding or
um you know Turnpike
funding Turnpike uh Capital needs for
example uh are not listed in in in in in
this Capital request uh turnike system
is its own enterprise system that is um
um captured in the um over
overall operating budget of the
department in the turnpike system
hopefully that answers your question
so in short most of this
is uh outside or not directly uh related
to the 10e plan except for the tie to
those FAA and FTA programs in the state
match contained in this request okay uh
last question for me the uh speaking of
the FAA match uh the 4.7 of General
funds versus the 62.6 million of federal
funds about a 13 to1 match for the
airports do you know how they base that
funding or that that match what they the
criteria they base it on and do they
give more or less considering the type
of airport whether it's like a
commercial one like Manchester or uh a
smaller one like Berlin or Mount
Washington right and that's a that's a
great question the uh the key to
understanding the differences in the
match are the types of projects that are
funded there so the FAA subdivides even
though we roll them all up into a state
match here for FAA related um uh pass
through or
grants Runway improvements along with
taxiway improvements are treated
differently than control control tower
improvements or rebuilding and each of
those has a different match which in
turn are different than terminal
building improvements it's these are
discrete types of Grants and
authorizations that FAA does Each of
which has slightly different matching um
and therefore it's a slightly different
match um uh balance between us and the
local airport between the state and the
local airport in addition to that an
added layer of complexity is the
recently passed fa reauthorization
act further subdivided that further
created um to our benefit um several
programs that are going to have a
further reduce match that's all
calculated in this request so that was
signed by the president May 15th um we
recalculated that to the
4,724 and change that we're requesting
so various levels of match depending on
the type of uh of
Grant but and I would just add it's in
list to the in in general most of the
GNC items and things that we take for
it's um typically 9 9010 so it's by and
large a lot of it is 90% federal funds
and the 10% match is typically split 5%
with the state uh contribution and 5%
from the um uh local or Regional Airport
contribution generally that's
yeah thank you any other questions
commissioner thank you um rail Trails I
appreciated your pitch um I like rail
Trails um why do you manage rail Trails
not the trails
Bureau yeah so that that has to do with
uh the underlying rail rights along uh
in active rail corridors which are
distinct from abandoned rail corridors
so if if a we usually retain the right
to um reestablish rail along our
corridors um believe me I wish I could
offload a lot of these segments it would
make our lives a lot easier we are not
the uh Department of trails uh and we
have one of those I just wonder if
there's a I mean the the ownership is
one thing right the the you know the
they happen to we also happen to be both
part of the same company yeah which is
the state but um it seems like they
probably have expertise in managing
trails that so we do partner quite
extensively with the NCR and we have a
rail trail plan that was completed last
year that
envisions um dncr managing uh different
type there's different types of uses and
when you look at rail Trails across the
country some are really used for daily
commuting you know especially near urban
areas most are recreation in our State
that's even more true there's only a
couple discrete rail trail segments that
we have toward the southern part of our
state that are actually used for
commutes for people that are using them
as as active transportation is what we
is the term of art um versus Recreation
and we are partnering with the NCR to
take over the the the full-time
management of several segments um but
we're in a conundrum as the NCR also is
not funded or man to manage these Trails
so we are in a Cooperative dance right
now yeah I would just add a lot of the
uh trails that that we own that have are
maintained for um recreational use there
is a Cooperative agreement with with um
the NCR um when storms happen when culs
fail when when uh wash outs happen uh it
does typically fall despite the the um
Cooperative agreement for for managing
if for rec ational use it typically
falls back on the on the owner to
replace that infrastructure and that's a
big part of where we fall down and
typically local clubs that pres like you
know Friends of the rail trail Etc don't
have significant cash well they they
have Manpower and they do their best
right they they could get out if if if a
little part of the trail has a wash out
you know that's where the local
volunteer groups come with sand and
wheelbarrows and try to fix it when when
you're talking about some of these
Bridges structures they are beefy they
are built uh you know to carry rail so
they're very significant structures and
they fail and uh the the age of some of
these structures is such that they're
failing at an increasing uh pace so not
something I could fix with a hammer and
scrap Lumber pretty tough pretty tough
um I have a question about um the ipd
software you have a half a million for a
consultant do you have a guesstimate of
of the ballpark procurement
of the actual
software you're going to buy you're
going to procure replacement software
presum we go out to bid I can Wing like
10 or 50 of it uh the existing system I
know when we procured it in uh 2014 was
about $3.5 million so I'm sure that's
gone up uh yeah probably a ballpark
figure would would be I would estimate
around $5 million for a full system but
that qualify that that that is a um
that's a little bit of a swag but based
on the fact that the existing system
that we did 10 years ago was about a 3
and a half million um development effort
um that's what I'm basing it on okay
thank
you um do any of the rail Trails allow
uh snowmobile
Recreation they do yes all of them uh
not all of them but but I again I I
don't want to get into the tap dancing
but a significant proportion of them do
isn't um the the trails Bureau don't
they collect a fee to help with the
maintenance of those
Trails yeah yes they do just to maintain
that's to maintain their
Trails okay I see when they don't
include yours that's correct all right
thank
you any additional
questions thank you very much for your
testimony thank you all appreciate it
and with that that concludes our
presentations for the uh capital budget
hearings uh I would like to thank uh the
governor the senator the representatives
who participated both today and
yesterday the LBA doit and a special
thank you to administrative Services who
did all the work uh they put together
these briefing books which are
instrumental to Our Success uh to the
extent these hearings have flowed
smoothly they get all the credit and if
you don't believe they did you can blame
me and it's mostly
Michelle Michelle carway who's our state
budget officer people know thank you
Michelle and with that we are
adjourned for